for as long as I can remember or at
least since I was four years old I
wanted to start a company by the age of
eight I had launched my first somewhat
successful venture which involved
reselling my mom's Evian bottles from
her fridge to construction workers in
our neighborhood she purchased these at
around a dollar fifty a bottle and I
resold them for fifty cents and they
sold out great but this was an early
lesson that even when your mom is your
investor it's important to generate a
positive return on capital for the
business to be sustainable fast-forward
20 years and I got that call the call
that we all know well that I had gotten
into Stanford Graduate School Business
it feels a lot like winning the lottery
we all know the stats less than seven
percent acceptance rate which means that
a lot of very qualified people who
deserve to be here don't get the chance
to so I felt pretty blessed and I was
very excited to be starting my
entrepreneurial journey that is until a
few weeks later I came across another
statistic that somewhere between one and
five percent of venture capital funding
goes to women entrepreneurs said another
way it is more likely to get into
Stanford Business School than it is to
be a woman entrepreneur who secures
venture capital funding I found this to
be shocking and as someone who came from
a background and investing and
fundraising I thought this is a great
business idea it must be there must be a
market deficiency that I could solve
through a company it's even the case
with the popular show shark tank women
who pips themselves for shark tank are
less likely to receive capital and when
they do receive capital they're more
likely to be priced down by the Sharks
than their male counterparts so back to
my business if there's anything I've
learned as an investor it's that being
right on the wrong time frame is the
same thing as being wrong and turns out
i was a little bit late to the game
there's actually plenty of companies out
there that are doing this today serving
women entrepreneurs their alternative
capital markets through accelerators
through networks of professional women
but you don't hear about this in the
narrative today and so I'm asking myself
why when there are so many opportunities
for women entrepreneurs is the only
thing that you hear about is how
difficult it is I'd like to propose that
we need to reframe the discussion
because actually there's never been a
better time to be a woman entrepreneur
some private equity or some venture
capital firms do recognize this
opportunity first round capital in a
study of its ten years of operating
history found that women led ventures
outperform their mail only firms by
sixty-three percent but whether you're a
man or a woman as an entrepreneur it's
important to recognize that venture
capital isn't one size fits all it's not
the right solution for every business
questions that you should ask yourself
are how important is it to me to retain
control of my company how quickly do I
want to grow this business if you decide
that venture capital is right for you
it's also important to note that not all
venture firms are created equally some
specialized by industry others focus on
later stage versus early-stage gsv
alumna jessica heron who's the founder
of stella and dot recognized the
importance of finding the right capital
for her business she shopped around her
idea for a direct-to-consumer jewelry
business too many different investors
before finding the right one who believe
not only in her business model but also
the vision that she had for how quickly
she was going to get there it was
important to her to prioritize not only
her business but also her family and
arguably her wildly successful business
is well positioned today because of the
time that she took to find the right
capital provider outside of venture
capital there are so many resources
today in the form of crowdfunding and
equity funding and the great news is
that women are disproportionately
successful in these channels Kickstarter
reports that women led tech businesses
are more than twice as likely to be
successful in raising campaigns than men
another GSB alumna nejo Woodward is
using Kickstarter to prove early-stage
product market fit and gain customer
traction she's designing a line of dolls
and stories that are inspiring the next
generation of girls that they can be
women entrepreneurs or coders
journalists or politicians and she's
doing so through Kickstarter so the way
that Kickstarter and crowdfunding works
is that early contributors give capital
in exchange for goods or services
outside of traditional crowdfunding
there is equity crowdfunding in which
entrepreneurs can actually raise real
equity and women are also really kicking
ass in this channel as well Circle up
which is one of the leading firms in the
space reports that women are are more
than five times the successful raising
capital online then they are through VC
and more than nine times more likely to
raise capital online than they are
through traditional banks one woman
entrepreneur who raised capital through
circle app suggests that raising capital
online takes gender completely out of
the equation because most of the
communication is written
I'm optimistic about the future for
women entrepreneurs particularly because
some suggest that alternative capital
markets like circle up we're going to
outstrip venture capital within the next
ten years but as optimistic as I am
about the future it's important to
reflect back on where we've been i was
born in january 1988 into a world in
which women couldn't secure a business
loan without a male cosigner within my
lifetime women gained access to this
fundamental source of business financing
that's pretty staggering to me and yet
women have been creating businesses for
generations and successfully doing it
one example that's close to my heart is
my great grandmother Myrtle she started
a successful fine fashion business in
muncie indiana of all places in 1956
when most women were simply housewives
and she did so while raising two kids
she and the other women who've come
before me are my inspiration I hope that
this is just the beginning of the
conversation and that by sharing stories
of success we can start to change the
pattern because venture capital is all
about pattern recognition the more
successful women entrepreneurs that do
well with institutional capital they're
more likely investors will be to follow
the herd as an aspiring woman
entrepreneur myself I'm throwing my hat
in the ring will you join me thank you
you